HERE, WHAT IS THIS.
SHREDDED OF THEY ARE NOT
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Hannity: WELCOME TO YOU AT
"HANNITY."
BIG BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT.
THANKS TO OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL,
THE DEEP STATE RECKONING IS NOW
FULLY UNDERWAY.
YOU ARE WONDERING WHEN WHEN WE
GET TO THIS POINT.
WE ARE.
NOW THE QUESTION FOR DIRECTOR
WRAY TONIGHT OF THE FBI.
HOW DO YOU WHICH DELL MIGHT WISH
BE REMEMBERED?
AFTER BOMBSHELL DEVELOPMENTS IN
THE SET OF CASE AGAINST
LIEUTENANT GENERAL MICHAEL
FLYNN, WE NOW HAVE TWO LAWMAKERS
THAT ARE CALLING ON THE FBI
DIRECTOR TO INVESTIGATE THE
TROUBLING POLITICIZING AND
MISCONDUCTS SURROUNDING THE FBI.
HE HIMSELF HAD A FULL COMPLETE
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT TONIGHT.
ALSO AHEAD, JOE BIDEN, THE DNC,
THE MOB, AND YOUR MEDIA ALL
PANICKING OVER BIDEN’S ME TO
SCANDAL AND THE FACT THAT HE
DOESN’T HAVE A SLOW PITCH
ANYMORE.
A PARTIAL REOPENING TONIGHT IS
ALSO UNDERWAY.
AND AT LEAST 23 STATES, MANY
MORE SOON ONLINE TO OPEN.
BUT OUTRAGE IS GROWING AS
AMERICANS ARE VOICING THEIR
RIGHTFUL CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT ARE
YOUR CONAN MEASURES BEING TAKEN
BYBY A HANDFUL OF GOVERNORS.
A FULL REPORT ON THAT END UP
BREAKING NEW REPORT, YOU CAN’T
MAKE THIS UP, SEE THAT RIGHT
THERE.
THAT IS CALLED THE GIANT ASIAN
MURDER HORNET.
AND THAT’S COMING TO AMERICA.
IT’S ACTUALLY HERE.
AND IT’S SCARY.
WE WILL EXPLAIN.
FIRST, WE TURN TO OUR TOP STORY
TONIGHT.
BRENT NEW FILING TONIGHT, SIDNEY
POWELL WILL JOIN US IN A FEW
MOMENTS DISCLOSING THAT PREVIOUS
LORE IS JUST DISCOVERED.
HANDWRITTEN NOTES THAT HAVE JUST
BEEN TURNED OVER TO THE
PRESIDING JUDGE, AND MET AND I M
SULLIVAN IN THIS CASE.
WE ARTY KNOW HOW THEY CORRUPT BY
A VERY FEW HIGH-RANKING MEMBERS
OF COLONIES FBI NEARLY DESTROYED
THE LIFE OF GENERAL FLYNN.
THEY HURT HIM, THEY HURT HIS
FAMILIES, THEY HAD TO SELL HIS
HOUSE.
AND HE WOULDN’T LIE.
BY THE WAY, IN 2016 WHILE MOST
FEDERAL AGENTS WERE BUSY
PROTECTED FROM TERRORIST,
VIOLENT GANG MEMBERS, OTHER
SERIOUS THREATS, WE HAVE A FEW
HIGH-RANKING OFFICIALS, THEY
WERE MORE CONCERNED WITH WHAT WE
NOW KNOW TO BE A SICK, TWISTED
POLITICAL VENDETTA AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP AND EVERYONE AROUND
HIM.
AND BASICALLY WHAT WAS AN
ATTEMPT AT A SOFT COOL AFTER
THEY DID SUCCEED.
IN HELPING PREVENT HIM FROM
GETTING ELECTED.
THEY WERE HELPING HILLARY.
NOW LIEUTENANT GENERAL, MICHAEL
FLYNN, THIS IS ONE PART OF A
MUCH LARGER POLITICAL HIT JOB.
NOW, HERE’S WHAT WE KNOW.
BEFORE HE WAS SWORN INTO OFFICE,
A AGGRESSIVE FBI INVESTIGATION
FOUND ABSOLUTELY ZERO DEROGATORY
MATERIAL ON GENERAL FLYNN AFTER
THEY HAD INVESTIGATED IT.
THEY KNEW THE NARRATIVE WAS A
COMPLETE AND TOTAL B.S.
THEY KNOW IT COMPLETELY.
AGENTS, WELL, THEY SAID LET’S
CLOSE THIS CASE.
AND THAT IS UNTIL NOW.
THEY SENT TO AGENTS TO AMBUSH
THE BRAND NEW NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR IN THOSE "ALWAYS CALL
THETELL MY CHAOTIC DAYS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION."
HE SENT THEM HIS OWN WORDS,
AMBUSHED GENERAL FLYNN.
THOSE AGENTS EVEN STILL COLD
CONCLUDED HE WAS BEING TRUTHFUL.
THAT IS, AND BY THE WAY, EDITED
AGAIN.
GREAT COUPLE.
AND BOOM, JUST LIKE THAT, THEY
INVENTED A CRIME.
THEY ACCUSED HIM OF LYING.
REMEMBER LAST WEEK, WHAT IS OUR
AIM?
PERJURY?
ADMISSION?
PROSECUTION?
THE ONLY GOALS OF THE FBI AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SHOULD BE
JUSTICE.
EQUAL APPLICATION, EQUAL, YOU
KNOW, USE OF OUR LAWS.
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
ULTIMATELY, THEY’VE FORCED HIM
TO PLEAD GUILTY.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY THREATEN TO GO
AFTER HIS SON AND PUT HIS SON IN
JAIL.
AND AFTER THAT, HE COULDN’T PAY
HIS LEGAL BILLS.
IN THE END, THEY HIT A MOUNTAIN
OF WHAT WE NOW KNOW WAS
ESTIMABLEINFORMATION FROM A LEGA
NOW WE KNOW THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
THAT FLYNN WAS EVER COLLUDING
WITH ANY FOREIGN GOVERNMENT OR
THAT HE EVER LIED TO THE FBI.
THEY THOUGHT JUST THE OPPOSITE.
IT WAS NEVER COMPROMISED IN ANY
WAY.
AND WHAT HAPPENED TO HIM AS
NOTHING MORE THAN A POLITICAL
PERSECUTION.
AND YEAH, A SOFT COOL ATTEMPT BY
THE FBI.
NOW THAT’S MY ASSESSMENT.
IT WASN’T JUST FLYNN, BY THE WAY
WAY.
ROGER STONE, ON THIS WEEK.
PAUL MATTER FOR.
HE IS NOT WELL PHYSICALLY.
WHAT DO THEY ALL HAVE IN COMMON?
DONALD TRUMP.
AND BECAUSE OF THEIR CONNECTION,
THEY WERE ALL SPIED ON,
INTERROGATED.
AT THE RECORDS EXAMINED WITH A
FINE TOOTH COMB.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF HURTING
DONALD TRUMP.
AND BY THE WAY, TWO CASES YOU
HAVE HEAVILY ARMED S.W.A.T.
TEAMS.
AND PAUL MATTER COME OUT RIGHT I
HOMES IN THE DARK OF NIGHT.
NONVIOLENT, PROCESSED CRIMES.
29 GUYS IN TACTICAL GEAR.
AND CNN CAM HAS JUST HAPPENED TO
BE THERE.
BY THE WAY, THEY HAVE ACCUSED
OTHERS OF THEM SELVES COMMITTING
THESE PROCESSED CRIMES.
AND THE NEED TO HAVE AN
INVESTIGATION INTO SUCH A
POSSIBLE REFERRALS.
ANOTHER QUESTION IS, FOR THE FBI
DIRECTOR.
WE KNOW JOHN DURHAM, THEY FORCED
THIS ISSUE ON GENERAL FLYNN.
THEY PUSH TO GET THIS
INFORMATION OUT.
THERE WAS MUCH RESISTANCE.
UNFORTUNATELY, WHERE?
WE DON’T QUITE KNOW YET.
WHY DIDN’T DIRECTOR WRAY GET
THIS OUT TO US.
YOU’VE BEEN THERE A LONG TIME.
THE DAM A NEW FLYNN EVIDENCE,
WELL, THAT WAS RELEASED PERHAPS,
PERHAPS, WE ARE GOING TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF IT, IN SPITE OF
DIRECTOR RIGHT.
HE HAS A LOT TO ANSWER FOR
TONIGHT.
DIRECTOR WRAY, DID YOU PROTECT
THE DEEP STATE INFRASTRUCTURE?
NOW, DO YOU WANT TO RESTORE --
THIS IS HIS CHALLENGE.
AMERICA’S FAITH AND IN THE WORLD
THIS IS AN FBI PIN RIGHT HERE.
THIS IS THE SOLIDARITY WITH THE
99% OF GOOD LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE
PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
WORLD.
THEY DESERVE THEIR GOOD NAME
BACK.
BECAUSE THEY DO THE RIGHT THING.
THEY PROTECT US, AND THEY RISK
THEIR LIVES.
OR, DIRECTOR, DO YOU WANT
JUSTICE TO PREVAIL?
OR ARE YOU MORE INTERESTED IN
PROTECTING OTHER WELL, FORMER
CORRUPTED INDIVIDUALS.
THEY ARE PRESSURING DIRECTOR
RIGHT TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
THEY SENT HIM A LETTER, IN THE
LETTER THEY SAY "THE OBAMA BIDEN
ERROR, RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION,
AS WELL AS DOCTORED EVIDENCE AS
A BASIS TO ILLEGALLY SPY ON A
TRUMP CAMPAIGN."
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR HAD SOME TO
SENSITIVE INFORMATION BETWEEN
TRUMP LEAKED TO THE MEDIA.
SHOULD HE WIN, I DON’T THINK YOU
WIN, HE HAS THE INSURANCE
POLICY.
NOW THE INTERACTIONS WITH FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
MICHAEL FLYNN MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT THE FBI’S WRONGDOING IS
WORSE THAN PREVIOUSLY KNOWN.
THAT’S TRUE TOO.
THESE REVELATIONS SHOULD JUST A
PATTERN OF MISCONDUCT
POLITICIZING AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF THE OBAMA BIDEN ERA
FBI.
WE ASK YOU TONIGHT, DO YOU HAVE
THE GOAL OF CLEANING UP THE
REPUTATION OF THE WORLD’S FINEST
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY?
IN OTHER WORDS, WILL YOU HOLD
THESE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE, OR TRY
TO PUSH IT UNDER THE RUG?
BECAUSE DIRECTOR WRAY, IF YOU
DON’T HAVE THE MORAL COURAGE,
LIKE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO
DID PUSH TO GET ALL THIS OUT.
HE IS SEEKING JUSTICE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IF YOU DON’T HAVE THE COURAGE TO
HOLD THESE FEW BAD APPLES
ACCOUNTABLE, WELL, YOU HAVE TO
MAKE WAY FOR SOMEBODY WHO DOES.
YOU NEED TO ADDRESS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND CONGRESS ON THIS
ISSUE.
BECAUSE DIRECTOR WRAY, THIS IS
THE SINGLE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
IF THIS CAN HAPPEN, IN THIS
CASE, AND WE DON’T FIX IT, WE
ARE GOING TO LOSE OUR COUNTRY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
ANSWERS.
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO TRUST OUR
FBI, OUR CIA, THOSE THAT WE
EMPOWER WITH THE MOST POWERFUL
TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE THAT THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO TURN THEM ON WE
THE PEOPLE.
WE NEED YOU TO LEAD THAT EFFORT.
IF NOT, CLEARLY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS LEADING OUT
OF HER.
AND HE IS FINDING THE TRUTH
WHEREVER HE COULD FIND IT.
MY SOURCES TELL ME TONIGHT THAT
THE REASON THE TRUTH IS BEING
TOLD IS THAT IT IS THE A G.
THAT WOULD BE BILL BARR.
THEY ARE INSISTING FOLLOWING THE